now in a desperate attempt to address
what are rising gas prices joe biden is
now begging opec
we weren't even getting a barrel of oil
from saudi arabia when trump left office
not one
begging opec to please
add up more production amp up more
production and pump more oil so we can
buy it from them
why don't we go back to the drum
policies joe
joe reduced the oil and gas supply
in the u.s to quote save the environment
and is now begging opec countries in the
middle east that hate our guts
to give us more oil and and produce more
oil
from a heavy polluting region
big government socialism always one big
false promise after another here on what
this will mean for you and your family
former energy secretary rick perry first
of all instead of begging opec why don't
we just go back to the trump era
policies that made us energy independent
for the first time in 75 years that
would be the obvious answer to me
it is stunning sean to see how fast
we went from energy independence
to now
relying on countries like iran to get
our energy you know i didn't think there
could ever be anyone
that would make me think that jimmy
carter might have had it right
but joe biden uh and and his policies
that he's putting in place uh making
jimmy carter look kind of good um and i
never thought i would say that but you
think about
where we were the work that we did the
americans that we put to work whether it
was building pipelines good union jobs
uh building pipelines all across the
country stopping that keystone uh
pipeline
out of canada and then allowing the
russians
to finish the nord stream too i mean it
it just makes absolutely no sense the
country that will hold the european
union hostage with energy just got the
green light
it it makes you kind of
question
you know what are on those
computers that uh
by himself lost well it's interesting we
have an investigation in our next
segment about hunter biden's computers
my question is
the obvious answer is
put the keystone pipeline up get it back
up and running continue drilling
governor abbott said come back to texas
let us drill again and we'll produce oil
faster than you can use it why don't we
go for the obvious hands why would we
beg countries
and kiss their ass when we don't need
their oil we've got enough
it is a
i can't answer it i mean it puts america
in a national defense weak position to
be able to when when the military
requires that fuel all around the world
and we're going to rely upon
uh countries halfway around the world
some of them that really dislike us when
you think about the iranians that this
is such a green light for them uh to go
do the terrorist acts against americans
and american allies around the world
and and the biden administration is
basically sending the message that it's
okay we
we will we will lay down
when you think about what the the the
taliban is is doing to this
administration and they're basically
making us come and beg them
to
how about how about if we give you some
foreign aid that that you let us come
and get our people out and and then
we'll be nice too
all right we appreciate it uh thank you
governor perry hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else